foreign
[Music]
I have dreamed my whole life about going
dog sledding and I've never gotten to do
anything remotely like it but also I
think the reason we wanted to come out
your way was because you're a good
person Jason you utilize rescue dogs and
you bring such attention what made you
want to do that there's a lot of sled
dogs that eat homes we don't have to
have dogs that are standout athletes we
just need dogs that want to do what
we're doing I'm sort of like the dog I'm
a lot of professional standout athlete
but I want to be there and get the job
done yeah I have three Chihuahuas can
you whip them in shape we could try we
could try
I know you also do such great work with
kids tell me about kids in snow oh it's
an event that goes on in West
Yellowstone Montana
um once a month all winter long and all
the different service providers for dog
sledding ice fishing nature hikes
snowshoeing snowmobiling cross-country
skiing all these different people come
together and we'll donate a day where
it's free for the kids it's about
showing everybody these kids everything
that Montana has to offer
so what do we need to know about this
dog sledding situation there's so
there's some basic rules that we want to
know first one is we're going to make
sure we hang on and then there's some
commands if you want to stop you put two
feet on the brake and you yell whoa whoa
I have to switch it up a little bit hold
on let me try again
whoa I mean you're also gonna have to
pry me away from each and every one of
these dogs so here here I'm gonna tuck
you in and now I feel like the queen
also well you know what we'll let you
yell much
it we're gonna start hooking these guys
up and all the dogs are gonna start
barking and jumping this is no different
from When Ross and I start the show we
just start you know barking and yelling
all right you hanging on Ross all right
let's do it Noah oh my gosh we're doing
it let's go let's go
oh my God
oh
did you say Mushrooms
I cannot believe we just did that that
was so cool uh my wife makes some really
cool little animals
do you recognize these little guys oh my
God that's Douglas and Lucy
so my wife had seen photos of your dogs
online so she made those for you so you
can always remember Montana
send us some pictures of your Chihuahuas
okay we will treasure this and if it's
okay we just also want to like donate
ten thousand dollars just to you know
doing the snow days with the kids or
some extra treats for the dogs and we
are so inspired by what you do it's
about living with purpose and intent and
you do it every day
yeah
I'll never forget that and you know I
never really thought about going to
Montana in the winter right but trust me
everyone at home you've got to go visit
downtown
West Yellowstone or another town close
by there are just so many different
things to do in these communities that
also give you easy access to and from
the park also yeah this was one of my
favorite trips I've ever been on I will
never forget that dog sledding moment
a huge thank you to visit Montana for
this incredible experience we will be
back to Montana and we will be right
back here
foreign
[Music]